i was reading an article in the new york
times and it was about um these
malibu homes and how like the these
crazy rich guys are coming in and buying
these homes and grant cardone was one of
the features and they didn't feature him
as grant cardone they're like another
local buyer is motivational speaker and
real estate entrepreneur grant cardone
and you know he was just like a guy they
were interviewing not like this internet
and he recently bought a house in malibu
i think it was for 60 million dollars
and he was like i'm gonna spend another
i forget tens of millions of dollars
renovating it
and that's one of those things that when
you see people what they spend on their
personal real estate you know i mean
it's hard to fake that and i'm just
thinking who would have thought that
those things that he's selling would
make that much well
[Music]
i have a question when was the last time
that you have flown
i just flew last week oh no sorry not
last week last month hawaii where hawaii
how about before that
uh yeah i don't know when we went to
austin miami something like that so like
once a year at this point or once every
six months
yeah yeah i'm not flying a ton right now
um when you flew to hawaii did you fly
first class or coach
yeah first
so i uh
i went to idaho this weekend with ben
podcast ben and i spoke at an event
which we have to talk about convertkit's
new thing and i don't like to travel you
don't like to travel uh and this was
work related so like they wanted me to
speak at a conference and whenever they
want me to speak at a conference i say
yeah that's cool i'll come and speak but
you have to pay for a first class flight
for me and sarah my wife i'm like that's
a fair trade you don't don't pay me to
come because i like you but like i do
want you to pay for my flight and it has
to be first class because i don't like
flying coach well
my uh
flights got screwed up for some reason
both ways
and i had to fly like middle c like back
row because like basically the flight
got canceled and they like fit me on
these like last ones and i was flying on
this and i started thinking do you know
that stereotype a story of this like
rich billionaire and they say like oh
yeah you know even though he was a
billionaire he still flew coach
and like nothing changed like i think
the idea guys
nothing changed and
it's like that is
oh amazon all their desks were old doors
i tried to
dude i did that i did that to be cute at
our office it cost more to do that a
door isn't a door expensive
yeah i bought like the shittiest door
and it was like eighty dollars and then
we bought cinder blocks and it was like
a pain in the ass i'm like dude this
thing's in ikea for 25 bucks this is way
better
also
flat
that's a stupid story it's like maybe
like they had a door while they like
folded t-shirts on that door like for a
day while they waited for the real
supplies to come uh this whole like
flying coach as a rich person thing and
i'm not talking about like rich like
uh millions or tens of millions i'm
talking like when you hear billionaires
or hundreds of millions of dollars
people say this i think that is total
nonsense
and i tweeted that i'm like this is that
is just a lie any rich person that i'm
talking like real rich who says they do
that
they're lying and i want to see proof if
that's true and i had a bunch of really
really rich people holler at me and tell
me they do it and so do you know who
palmer lucky is so palmer lucky started
uh he created oculus which he sold for
he is in the ballpark of billions of
dollars and he has a new company worth
tens of billions so if he's not a
billion he's like
he's like right there basically he
tweeted back he's definitely a
billionaire that guy's definitely a
billionaire dude he tweeted back to me
and he said i only fly coach and then i
had a other i had yeah and i think
that's crazy i had other some other
people dm me they go and who i know the
companies public and they're like i'm
worth hundreds of millions and i i'll i
fly first class no matter what
internationally but like i have no
problem taking southwest if it's like a
short flight and i understand that
argument if it's like an hour but if
you're going from new york to la or some
anything above three hours
i don't believe it i think they're lying
i just think they're full of it i asked
darmesh on hubspot i'm like do you do
this he goes no that's a ridiculous
thing of course i don't do that
and he like had this
if you're like us at the my first
million podcast where we are cultivating
that trillionaire mindset that
multi-trillionaire mindset hashtag
grindset you have to even before you you
have multi-trillions you better be
flying private you better find private
when you can't afford coach because if
you can't afford your future can you
afford your present and that's how i
feel
i just thought it was the most
ridiculous thing when i was sitting in
this seat uh i was just like my back was
sore and it was just terribly
uncomfortable and it took forever
just the vibe of the peasants that
you're sitting next to it's awful
it sucked and i know i have a problem
doing i mean i i will do it but i'm just
saying if i could like
if i'm worth hundreds of millions of
dollars what's the difference between
fifteen hundred dollars and five hundred
dollar ticket and anyone who lies and
says otherwise i think they're an idiot
and they're lying
yeah
so some people were like oh bill gates i
read that thread because it's pretty
interesting they gave you a ton of
examples they like slams you with
examples of it happening
and i think the main they just told
these fake stories
well yeah so so that's the thing i think
the you know the main thing that they
were saying was like
ex person used to do this which is
either simply just their pr team being
like hey bill we need you to do a coach
like uh flight here and like you know
whatever we'll we'll keep your your
private jet and epstein's jet like off
the radar you know just so we can kind
of have this measure of austerity here
and so that you know i i'm pretty sure
it and because it works by the way like
the fact that so many people posted
articles
of billionaire flies coach it's like
dude that's not news by the way but the
fact that it's newsworthy
is
like more proof that this is likely a pr
stunt because i've done it too i've been
like oh you know bill you know
warren buffett you know still drives an
old beat up you know 83 you know camry
and like um you know oh sam banker freed
he's the newest young billionaire and
did you know that he only eats bananas
and sleeps on a bean bag and you know
like these stories work they're like
worth telling which makes me think this
is like a pr scheme
but the other interpretation was they
did it so that they could like tell the
company hey from the top down we're all
being frugal we're not wasteful so like
you know mr you know senior director of
business development is not like you
know flanked first you know to every
country i understand that but it's like
dude you and your three kids are taking
your vacation to france and you're going
to fly coach on spirit airlines yeah
that ain't that that ain't gonna happen
like that's right
you're you're lying you're lying it's an
absolute lie she'll be speaking
receipts if you're really doing this
like show me your spirit airlines
frequent flyer miles history if you
expect me to believe this like dude i've
sat in spirit air and i've had the pilot
come out mid-flight and rearrange the
seating because someone was too fat and
had to like hey we need to do a
two-for-one trade you need to get to the
left side of the plane and then two you
all need to move to the right we need
better balance like that's absolutely
unless you've done that you don't have
that trillionaire energy yeah dude i've
done that on pontoon boats like where
you have like
or yeah people in the back you're like
hey you guys gotta switch seats uh
there's boats going a little sideways
but i've never done that on the plane i
didn't even think it was real i thought
the pilot was joking and it wasn't a
joke they literally were like we need to
rebalance
jesus christ
let me tell you about one more
interesting thing another rich guy thing
so you know who grant cardone is of
course i know grant matt graham so
so i'm not gonna like even comment on if
i like him or not but i will like
okay that's cool i don't entirely
dislike him i don't dislike him i don't
really i don't like everything he does
and i like a lot of what he does um
and but i kind of paid him as this guy
that was kind of like in the internet
marketing world just selling like
talking like cheat books and cheap
courses and if you're so rich why are
you selling a course right yeah yeah
yeah yeah a question i've asked myself
many times also
yes speak it up and it's my course
available july 11th power writing sign
up today go to maven.com and sign up
baby
market's down daddy needs a new course i
was thinking about that i'm like all
right if if this is this course guy and
he has this like uh he's wearing all his
nice suits like is that legit is that
real and i was reading an article in the
new york times and it was about um these
malibu homes and how like the these
crazy rich guys are coming in and buying
these homes and grant cardone was one of
the features and they didn't feature him
as grant cardone they're like another
local buyer is motivational speaker and
real estate entrepreneur grant cardone
and you know he was just like a guy they
were interviewing not like this internet
and he recently bought a house in malibu
i think it was for 60 million dollars
and he was like i'm going to spend
another i forget tens of millions of
dollars renovating it and that's one of
those things that when you see people
what they spend on their personal real
estate you know i mean it's hard to fake
that and i'm just thinking who would
have thought that those things that he's
selling would make that much wealth is
that's pretty that's pretty crazy isn't
it you know what's even crazier so the
one time i talked to grant cardone for
an extended period of time like we had
like i don't know a 40 minute
conversation
20 minutes of it was on why buying a
house is so stupid and why he rents
everything
and he was going off like people were
like oh your penthouse is rented that
you're in he's like yeah bro your house
is not an asset why would i buy a house
and he was like he's like i buy real
estate that pays me brother and he's
like you know um
yeah i rent this penthouse i always rent
i rent everything i want to be able to
move i want to live in the place i like
and i take my money and i put it to work
you see that over there that's my money
working and you know because he's like
he's like a big-time showman right
and so uh what is it like dollar bills
like digging holes i don't like what's
he pointing at he's like he's like hold
on brother i can't hear you i got
something in my ear it's a voice tell
it's asking me one question who's got my
money and that's what i gotta ask every
every morning i wake up and i look to
the heavens and i say who's got my money
and then i go and i get that money from
them and i was like well this is
incredible
[Laughter]
wait where'd you where did you hang out
with him for 45 minutes so he used to
use blab the same product that where i
met martin shkreli i've it attracted a
whole bunch of grifters and
grant cardone was there and i was like
all right who's that i would go into all
the rooms that had a big following i was
like okay this guy's driving a bunch of
a growth and engagement you're a power
user who are you and sure enough like
you know it was it was often you know
people who are
you know somewhat controversial that's
who people like to watch live stream and
so grant would go on there and he would
do his 10x
meetups and he would just see people
come in they'd be like
uh i got to keep doing my impressions it
was so if you haven't gone into this
world by the way
you need to spend three hours and i need
you to i love watching his videos
he's got great videos
watch his uh watch his community because
you'll be like wow this is like the
kool-aid drinker so they would come on
they'd be like grant
they put up their uncle g uncle g what's
up man what's up brother and they'd be
doing the 10x 10x all right uh thank you
so much for all the content man i was i
was broke and homeless i used to eat
mcdonald's wrappers instead of the food
and now um i just had i got a ruth chris
uh subscription membership
and i just want to say thank you and i
had a question for you right so they
would do this and then it would be one
after another of
uh grant grant 10x 10x brother um just
want to thank you before i was thinking
where the sky's the limit and now the
sky is the floor am i right amen brother
and so they were doing this stuff and i
was like wow these people are like
really like this these are the converted
right so a lot of people really found
value in this thing um because this
wasn't like a recorded testimonial this
is a live stream where random people are
calling in and it'd be very hard to like
fake this and they're wearing the hat
they're holding up the books they're
like they really liked his stuff and
i've never heard of this guy he's like
in the tech world you don't you don't
know who this character is right like
and you're if you're in real estate you
know if you're in the motivational self
self-help thing you know but he's not
leaving like ty like tai lopez crossed
all boundaries people like all knew who
he was uh grant cardone's like not like
that that's the first thing you should
watch second thing is
he does these deal
breakdowns
very interesting to watch so
he's sitting at a at a table
and it's like you know what's that guy
ramsay dave ramsey who like you called
in and you're like dave i make 80 000 a
year and i got student debt like what
should i do and he's like save your
money and so people do that with grant
they're like hey grant i got 200 000 i'm
looking at a property the address is
3909 you know west boise street and in
idaho whatever and then people and he'll
go and he he basically googles it he's
got a white board behind him and he
basically he's like talking to the guy
he's like all right so what are you
putting down all right what terms are
they giving you and he basically like
workshops the deal with them he like
kind of like uh
sort of like a speed version of
underwriting the deal live and i've
actually learned a bunch from it like
i'm sure somebody who's like you know a
real estate master is probably like oh
this is all just like
this is the jim cramer of like real
estate here where he's saying things
that make it sound smart but he's
actually not considering xyz but just
from a like
if you're a beginner in real estate
which i am you will learn a bunch and
you'll be entertained just in the style
and he does things so i like that the
last thing he's like uh it's like the
price he's he's got like pro wrestling
vibes
yeah exactly and that's why i'm doing
the impersonations because i'm like why
i said i like him i like him because
he's entertaining like i like him
because i've learned some stuff and i've
been very entertained through the rest
like have you seen these videos on
youtube where he just does sales calls
for an hour
i have i think i they're so good i think
they're fake yeah it might be fake
because he'll be like
he's always pulling a rabbit out of a
hat and you're like oh dude it's like a
pickup artist it's like you watch their
video you're like oh my god
you know she was uh she was like
literally just she was running she was
getting into her cab but he said this
one thing and she got out of the cab and
started talking to him this guy's
amazing and you're like wait a minute
maybe he just like edited like three
really good ones out of 500 failures
into this video that's kind of what it
feels like but he's doing an hour of
continuous sales calls and so it might
be scripted where the guy on the other
line is like yeah i'll say yes just call
me yeah we'll play we'll role play here
it's like the tv show pawn stars you're
telling me like holy [__] and one day
you had a guy come in with like a like a
civil war gun a guy who had napoleon's
hat and another guy that owns a picasso
all in las vegas coming into a park
that's crazy yeah it's like dude the
undertaker was dead and then he came
back to life and won the match it's like
yeah yeah you're falling for a scripted
drama right like
so it might be that but nonetheless
these sales calls are very entertaining
to listen to and like
they're it's obviously like very wolf of
wall street style like
macho sales but
i like to see it because i've never seen
anything like that like first of all i
don't do phone sales that's not like
it's not even like in my life
secondly
i don't know people who are as
ridiculous as grant cardone and are
willing to say things as ridiculous as
grant cardone and third like
this is not a style of communication or
sales ship i've i think you can read or
study or intuit and so it's just nice to
like see it so anyways
i've gone down these rabbit holes of
grant cardone and i've come out the
other side being like
yeah he is definitely self-promoting and
he's making most of his money it seems
like on the like
the brand and not the like meat and
bones of his business
but um you know respect he hustles
really hard he's a good self-promoter
and he
is smart and like you know he does well
so you know i i don't think that
you're you're not learning from somebody
who's a hack uh like he's somebody i
don't think he's a hack i don't think
he's a heck at all i think the criticism
isn't that
well i think maybe i just don't always
agree in his values but i don't think
he's lying right
i think the criticism would not be this
guy is dumb or lazy or anything like
that the criticism would be
um
he's just selling you you know a bag of
dreams basically and like
you know he makes his money on people
who want to be him and want to be like
him and they're not really going to be
like him and he's sort of like you know
promoting that dream i would say that
that's probably true but i think that's
true of a lot of things in life like
that's true of nike also like would i go
buy nike sneakers you know because
michael jordan wore them do i really
think michael jordan's a scumbag for you
know i'm not he's not tricking me into
thinking i can i could be like mike but
yeah that is actually what the
commercial literally says
dude i'm i'm working on this new thing
and i want to tell you two things about
it i'm working on this new business and
i'm like i'm still like mvping it out
and making sure it's legit
and i i i've got six figures in revenue
now six figures of cash in the bank
um
and
it was all from phones i from calling
calling constantly no website a type
form
and calling them and then setting a
stripe link so what's if what are you
doing that's effective on the call give
me the give me the strategy of the call
uh without sharing so i don't want to
show i'm not and i'm not really selling
so basically the thing that i'm making
like a community for a particular
salesman claim
i'm not here to sell you anything
well because because here's here's the
thing
no offense but of sales
so the the place where the business is
at right now which is like i only want
like let's say 50 people to join right
now i don't want a lot of people to join
because i want to make sure that it's
like legit and good and also because
it's an exclusive like private paid
community i need to make sure that like
each person actually can provide value
for one another so i can't just let
anyone in i can only let in the type of
person who makes like the true person
feel yeah feel more valuable right they
came in
so in a way i'm like no like i'm i
really like i don't know if i have space
for you i don't know if we can make this
work um but we may be and that's why i'm
here to interview to see if this will be
a good fit for you and uh that's
basically what i'm doing it's like i
also you're using the [__] line but
this time it's not actually [__]
it's real this time
i i i yeah i guess that's true but like
i don't know how to explain it it is
true like we we only have a certain i
can only make it truly work for a few
amount of people otherwise it sucks and
so remember how
we interviewed the chief folks she said
they had 60 000 people apply it but they
only have like 10 or 15 000 members so i
kind of believe it um
uh but anyway i'm working on it and i
went to this i'm starting it with uh my
friend joe and we did something
interesting the other day
and when i had started companies in the
past i did i partnered with the wrong
people not every time but sometimes and
and the mistake that i'm trying to not
make this time is basically making sure
i partner with the right folks
you're saying partner like business
partner not like an external partnership
you're talking about like your
co-founder type of thing
business partner like someone who you
give a substantial amount of equity to
um which is very similar to a marriage
and i actually did this in my marriage
but i've never done this in a business
partner uh but we basically like said
like hey like separately write down
three things write down what like what
does success look like to you in 10
years
what are you willing to give up in order
to achieve that
and um like just your day-to-day like
what what do you value and how do you
want to get there and so we each wrote
that down and we came together and we're
like all right here's all the things
that are important to me let's look at
what's important to you oh wow they
actually align really nicely this thing
doesn't align is that a game breaker for
you and then we and then there was
another thing that we went through
scenarios we're like let's say you're
lance armstrong
it's 1999 you know that everyone's
cheating
and you have to cheat if you want to win
what are you gonna do right like how how
do you want to play like what do you
want to play and there's no right or
wrong answer but it's just like let's
just see how our values align in
different scenarios and so anyway we've
been doing this thing where we're like
trying to figure out why won't this
partnership work let's get all that out
of the way at first and it has been
awesome more people should do this have
you ever done this uh i have actually
done that which is so funny you say this
we did something so similar we sort of
stumbled upon it organically at our
first business because
the first business i ever created was
that sushi business and uh the idea was
to create like a chipotle-like
restaurant chain for sushi and so we're
going about it we've been at this at
this point we've been doing it for i
don't know
six to nine months something like that
so we're not like it's not like it's not
like day one we've already already
committed we already have the equity
splits and we're all best friends we've
known each other for four years so like
surely we know everything about each
other right
and a smarter business person kind of
like a mentor type dude was like
at this time we were really big on
mentors and he was like oh um
he was like you know
um how aligned are you guys he's like if
i so it was the guy we wanted to partner
with the chef he was like
he flew each of us out one by one to la
and hung out with us and he told us he
was like
yeah i feel like all of you guys say the
same words but they mean different
things and i was like what do you mean
he goes like you all be like you know oh
man this what really matters is that we
do this like uh the right way he's like
but i think you all have a different
definition of the right way or like we
yeah we all want this to be a success
i i think if i asked you what do you
mean by success like put a number put a
time frame around it like i bet you it's
all different and so we came home he
totally gave us that feedback
and we did it we did the same exercise
we go i created a list of questions and
we all went sat in our corner of the
room silently and we wrote our answers
and then we came and we compared and
jesus they were so different me and one
guy were pretty lined and the third guy
and we all thought we were all totally
alive the third guy his was like way
different and the biggest differences
were like time scale like how long do
you how long do you expect to work on
this before we see any like any like
tangible success what are your
expectations on that and then what would
be a win for you and it was like one guy
was like oh man like if i could be
making six figures and like you know and
you know i'll do this forever and then i
was like oh dude i want to like i want
to make 10 million dollars in you know
three years and the other guy was like
somewhere in the middle and then we were
like oh wow like we all have like you
would be happy with one path and i would
be completely unhappy if that same thing
we both are and if we didn't talk about
it our definition of success would have
been very different and the same thing
with values of like what for one for two
of us it was super important like look i
don't know if this business is going to
work or not
but i want to do it our way like the
thing that makes this fun for me like
there's a lot of shitty components to
doing this business
the part that makes me like want to wake
up and do it every day is that i feel
like we're putting our own stamp on this
and for the other guy he's like yeah
that's cool but like i don't really care
about that and we're like oh shoot it's
important to know how important it is
because so we're going to spend a bunch
of energy doing it yeah well it was
clarifying like we were sort of
the partner
the partners yeah well that's what i'm
saying you got to do this early on
because
in a way a business partnership is
actually
more of a commitment commitment than a
marriage because with the marriage you
can just like
end it and be over with a business
screwing up your cap table and someone
owning a portion of your i mean that
could be it it's just a it's just kind
of an irreversible decision and the only
way that you reverse it is by spending a
lot a lot a lot a lot a lot of money
yeah like what we did what was lucky for
us was that we were all 21 years old so
we were all like a blank slate it's like
dude i don't know this is just my first
thought i'm not like married to this
to this belief system you know like so
it was very few things that we were like
no i am certain and i'm stubborn on that
point now in my life if i said something
if i may if i answered ten questions
eight out of the ten would be things i'm
like no i stand by that like that's
really that is what i've thought this
through and that's what i believe
back then it was like i don't know i
hadn't really thought about it but if
you had now you're asking me to
articulate it so i'll just say these
things so what happened in our thing was
we kind of we would all hear each
other's answers and then we would be
like oh i like that that's right let's
all agree to align on that and we were
like yeah like sure that sounds better i
don't know what the [__] i was thinking
it was that wasn't i'm not married to
that and so it worked for us because it
got us to like get to a right answer
versus who's right you know what i mean
yeah this exercise that i've been doing
um with joe we should be wonderful
publish this by the way because you know
we i think we talked about this one time
was like some new york times article
that was like 17 questions you should
ask your future spouse or something like
that like before it was like it was like
27 questions to ask on the first date
like as a single guy who just wanted to
like meet girls i was like oh i'm just
going to ask it was like 27 questions to
like make someone fall in love with you
or something like that and it was like
for like relationships and i was like oh
i'm asking every woman this like this is
the first day question this is the first
hour first day question
and i remember doing it like three times
and like those [__] at them new york
times they didn't know what the hell
they're talking about none of these
people like me
okay yeah maybe i misremembered so we
should but i do think it would be useful
whatever you and joe just did because i
did this like i don't know 10 12 years
ago now uh i think you did it just like
last month so you should definitely like
compile these so that more people can
can do this because it'll save
it'll straight up save people years of
pain in their life if they like can
identify some of these things up front
versus just rushing in to the
co-founding yeah i mean i i i like it
was like all right so here's what i want
just in my personal life and i put like
a net worth um i said i want i want to
have a seat at the big boys table and i
want people to think that i know what
i'm talking about when it comes to
business i want freedom i want to be
able to live in different cities with my
family i want to be president my
children's lives i want to own a bunch
of real estate i want to have fun and
adventure uh and i want to work like
really hard for three or four weeks or
for
uh six or seven months and then i want
to chill for like three months
uh and then it was like all right and
ways i want to get there is i want to
build this particular business i don't
want a boss i don't want to have any
meetings i want a few if any employees
reporting to me
um and then it was
the ways in which i'm going to approach
this particular business i want to be
incredibly aggressive about it i want to
treat it like a job so we're working 40
hours a week on it i want to have close
to no standing meetings few employees
and basically that's it yeah oh and a
revenue target of 100 million dollars in
five years i don't care if we actually
hit that but i want that to be the
target and then he like answered
similarly on a lot of those it's like
all right there's like some alignment
here
nice nice okay i like that and um
yeah okay i think yeah i think you
should i think you should publish some
of those things also the lance armstrong
things i think those are if nothing else
like
it doesn't it doesn't really matter but
it's like at least knowing how the other
person is wired and being like am i okay
with this
am i okay with the weird
psychology of this person
um i think it's not so much that do all
of our answers match just like in a
marriage it's not do we do we think the
same way about everything it's like do
we think the same way about the really
important things
um
all right so what did you say would you
would you if you're in the land
situation what do you do i for sure
cheat uh you basically have two options
you either exit the sport
or you cheat right like uh it's not even
cheating at that point when everybody is
doing it it's just the new normal right
like there's not a
it'd be one thing if it's like
is if one person's cheating and they're
winning and everybody else is clean
would you would you cheat to try to win
or would you stay clean
it was like my belief is that all these
olympic sports plus pretty much all
professional sports are full of pd's and
uh
like you know it's just a it's just a
naiveness test whether you believe that
people are clean or not it's like in the
same way it's like
oh my god what percentage of nba players
you think cheat on their wife
it's like um
like you know
i don't know but
yeah the answer is yes not a not a
number
and so
like there might be one outlier and like
cool you know credit to that person for
for being the the
you know the the outlier the ac green of
this but but i think
same thing with cheating so yeah that
one's the easy one for me
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot grow better
dude you wanna you've got some you wanna
like quickly go through some of your
topics or do you wanna uh
talk about a company that i had listed
that what do you wanna do uh let's do
one of yours and then we'll be one of
mine we'll finish up
all right um have you heard of this
company called n2 publishing no what do
they do the reason i like this story is
because
they're succeeding wonderfully in a
place that everyone thought that it was
impossible to succeed so it's called n2
publishing they just rebranded it like
last week to stroll and it's basically
neighborhood magazines so magazines in
like upscale neighborhoods and i'm
almost positive they have like 800 of
these or 650 of them but they're all
print so it's like in your
in like danville or in like the nice
suburb i don't even know what the like
the very specific neighborhood you're in
what it would be i don't live there but
blackhawk is like are you in black no no
but blackrock's an example of a nice
neighborhood in danville
so what they do is they send you a
magazine like once a month and it's just
a magazine it's like a bulletin it's
like it's like a newsletter i don't know
what you want to call it but it's
literally physically a magazine
and the company has like 250 employees
most all the employees are ad sales
people and they hire someone and not
exactly hire they friend it's a
franchise so someone who lives in
blackhawk pays like five or ten grand to
become the official publisher of that
area and that person has to gather a
couple stories every single month but
like the stories really are like they're
not that good but it's just like people
there's this old like uh
idea with local publishing we're like
dude people don't care about the writing
they literally just want to see people
they know and their friends and places
they know in a newspaper and you can
just list all their names and they would
like that and that's kind of what they
do
and it's just like a magazine every
month and it says here's what's going on
like uh uh you know the local high
school had their graduation and like
eight people went to stanford um
like this new restaurant opened and the
guy is a greek immigrant and he's
bringing some of his greek like taste to
the area and like the fed is amazing and
like that he just like goes from thing
to thing so anyway it's a bootstrap
business that's been around for like 18
years and they announced that they're
doing like 150 million dollars a year in
revenue and they've been profitable
every single year
and they don't have a website so like or
they the hq has a website but each
individual magazine there's no website
it's 100 done through through paper
and everything that they're doing
is something that you would say like it
it can't be done
and it's kind of killing it it's kind of
it's kind of a major business isn't this
one so how did you get these numbers did
they is it something public that like do
they have all their numbers
uh yeah so if you google stroll
axios they just did a big um
announcement on axios last week where
the founder and the ceo kind of get he
gave the revenue he said we do 130
million dollars in revenue we have 18
000 plus advertisers wow um we've been
profitable every single year we expect
rev revenue to double every four years
that was an uh i believe an exact quote
and we're just expanding to all these
cities and we changed our name from n2
to stroll
um
it's kind of a really fascinating story
i guess if it's doubling every five
years that means it's growing what like
uh 10 uh 10 or 15 a year so it's not
like killing it but it's doing pretty
good yeah 14 a year wow this is
i mean you've done it again a sample
special like how do you find these
businesses this is amazing
it's pretty wild no literally that's a
real question how did you find this
business
uh i just read like
there's this blog i read called flash
and flames there's this blog i read
called flash and flames if you google
flash and flames it's just some guy
named colin in england who just writes
about cool b2b
uh media companies and i just i read
like loads of trade publications like
trade publications that has like
literally 500
website visits a day
like just the most niche stuff i read it
and if you google if you dude google it
it's hard to even find their website the
only way you find it is you type the
ceo's name is dwayne hixson and so you
have to type in like n2 because there's
like 10 or 20 companies called n2
n2 and then dwayne hixson and that's how
i found it and when i did a little
research on him i think they're it's
heavily rooted in christian stuff
because their
their mission is like to like to bring
like to create jobs and value people and
to bring glory to god and we're just so
happened to be doing it through like
creating this like newspaper thing uh
and so that's our podcast or the stairs
both
so anyway like it's just kind of an
interesting guy outside of our world uh
really fascinating this is great i
wonder how many more of these there are
like i could imagine somebody doing
for again doctor's office daily or
doctor's office monthly or whatever
doctor's office magazine and you just go
to every doctor's office and you're like
hey here's you know this awesome
magazine for whatever for doctors who
run their practices and you just if you
eat the cost of the print
then you're like you could basically go
to advertisers and pharmaceutical
companies and be like hey
yeah we have
15 000 doctors offices that read and
subscribe to our thing
um
and you know you should advertise but
here's the thing like
selling local ads so they're selling
like the advertisers advertisers are
like local dentists local realtors
selling ads to those types of people is
really hard because you're selling like
500 ads that's a hard business you just
have to be like smile and dial you know
you gotta do it constantly so like maybe
they threw that whole godstick in there
because they're like but you're doing it
for the will of god therefore you have
to be like
that's the only way that you can
motivate someone in order to like be on
the phone all day selling uh a 500 ad to
kathy in scottsdale arizona about coming
to her open house
that's a hard sell that's a grind that's
a grind ben ben did it for two years he
probably wouldn't want to do it for
three or four more years it's a hard job
but but what i'm saying is if you did
this for other
just say other like subgroups right so
like doctor's office you wouldn't then
need to advertise locally because you
could advertise
like to all the companies that sell to
medical professionals or like if i
created you know ecom you know shopify
mag right and i sell i send this to
every shopify owner's home and i'm just
putting out like awesome case studies
about
e-commerce and just cool like stories of
brands or whatever and then i just go
tell klavio and postscript and like
every e-commerce company every company
that sells to e-com stores like every
shopify app i'm like yeah you should
advertise in this thing we have like you
know pretty like
pretty like hyper targeted distribution
basically the question is is this better
than a newsletter like you know you you
know both spaces we know that andrew's
doing this local news thing but for
not neighborhoods but it's for like
local cities and he's doing it through
newsletter right his company overstory
uh what's better this magazine idea or
newsletters in your opinion
so i actually think that's the wrong
question the the because the what's
what's quite interesting is that they're
selling a franchise which is very weird
for a media company
that is actually the more interesting
thing um do i think that this i think
this is an awesome business do i think
it's better than a newsletter no i would
probably do that the newsletter but i
would consider doing it this way where
you're like you're like hey like we have
10 000 people already pre-signed up to
for uh this small neighborhood in
arizona if you want to you want to buy
this list from us as a publisher it's a
10 000 buy-in and we'll monetize it for
you and you get 15 of all the revenue
that we sell but you got to make sure
that you put it out all the time
um that is that's kind of an intriguing
that's an intriguing business model the
do i think that it's better because it's
in print i definitely think it's
potentially more interesting i think the
ad rates could potentially be higher
because i think that like it is actually
quite cool to hold and see something i
think it's a very fascinating business
model um i think you could also do this
with a lot of different things what is
the did they say anything about the cost
of actually the print in the delivery
like you have to print in mail magazines
right which is uh
gonna cost you something so that's
that's like the biggest
difference from like a newsletter you
get the tracked clicks
and you get no you have no hard costs
for the for the print and for the
shipping and the and the printing of the
magazine do you know at all what that
costs
no i don't so they didn't reveal too
much but they basically said that their
national team has editorial oversight on
what's published to ensure editorial
editorial standards are non-partisan and
community focused news
they keep a cut of all ad revenue they
have local operators so the people who
run the local papers
the local magazine used stroll's
national printing copy editing and
operational resources and the company
distributes the magazine for free in
readers mail
right
it's pretty it's it's pretty fascinating
it's an interesting business you know
what else is kind of interesting did you
hear what convertkit so convertkit is
like a mailchimp competitor i went to
the conference this weekend it's a email
platform i think you use them right yeah
i use them
do you see the thing they loki announced
something that's kind of amazing so and
the reason this is actually quite
fascinating they launched this thing
where they now hired an ad sales team
and they're going to go out and sell ads
and they're going to give you sean the
user uh 85 of the revenue that they go
and sell
yeah this is smart i was always
wondering why the like
email platforms don't do this because
once you start your newsletter you're
like alright cool you get people being
like hey can i sponsor it you're like
yeah and then you de facto become ad
sales and guess what you're like not
great at it because you're not doing it
fully
it sucks and you would happily pay
somebody a 15 commission
for filling your ad spots
and doing it well and i was always
thinking like you know a sort of a
mailchimp a beehive convertkit like why
aren't they just making this their
business model like in addition to their
sas revenue of like paying for the email
stuff
like couldn't they you know convert it's
at pretty significant scale like i
wonder
how big this is going to be for them
dude listen to this the hustle there was
a period of time where trung was on fire
and he was our only writer he basically
we had like people that would kind of
fill in when he was sick but basically
he wrote the email by himself every day
for like eight months and we were doing
over a million dollars a month in
revenue right and there was one trunk
and there was like 20 ad sales people
that's ridiculous that is crazy it was
pretty crazy and then we had like atoms
so we had like four
uh like growth marketers so like but it
that business could have been trung and
like four growth marketers and it could
have been making over a million dollars
a month and
but it had we had like eight or ten or
fifty i don't remember exactly ad sales
people and then each like for ad sales
person needs an operations person and
then like uh uh editors to edit the ad
it was like
like morning brew i think has 250 people
i don't know for a fact i would bet you
that morning brew has
30 editorial people
and
ad sales or ad sales related people
well there's some management overhead
but like
so with your ad sales yeah managing the
the the sellers when you when you had
your ad team you you probably had like
some commission structure or whatever
right like um hey yeah four percent
yeah so so what how did you accommodate
them and basically what so what was your
comp model and then what is what was
like the overhead so the fact that you
employed them versus them just being
let's say like with convertkit for
example if i write a newsletter i'm not
paying for the overhead i'm only paying
for the placement i pay this 15
placement fee once they once they get me
an ad that's their commission
well did you spend more or less than
that in overall ad sales for the hustle
do you think
so we basically when we kind of were
getting going we had two salaries
like the entry-level people so the
people who were like
um two or three years
of experience and then we had the higher
people which for us was like five or six
years experience so still not a lot of
experience but i was only 24 when i
started it so it was basically like a 22
year old and like a 27 year old like
those are like do you get my jokes or do
you not get my jokes
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and uh the the earlier ones
uh the younger guys it was like around
it ranged from like 50 to 70 000 a year
in base salary and then the upper guys
got like a hundred to like 120 000 a
year in base salary in the upper guys
there it was expected that they would
sell
i forget exactly but between one to 1.5
million dollars a year in ad revenue and
they would get four
either four or four and a half percent
of that uh the younger guys their
expectations was that they were going to
sell between 500 and like 900 we had
some sellers like this woman katie who
would sell i believe the year we sold
she was going into the year with like
2.5 million booked 2.5 million and and
so but um so basically but then they had
to get 75
of their quota so if their quota was one
million dollars if they hit only 600 000
they only got their base salary if they
hit 75 of their quota that's when the
four percent started kicking in and then
if they got 101 then the kickers would
go up and they would start making a lot
of money so the highest paid person at
our company oftentimes was a ad seller
and do you remember like did you just
look at like uh what is our percent of
revenue that we're paying out in
commissions like did you have like
because let's just say the easy apples
to apples math is
let's say convertkit launches this thing
it's 15
and that's your that's your cost of ad
sales basically um if if they placed all
your ads do you remember what your you
can over simplify it
yeah you could oversimplify it by saying
uh
4.4 of total ad revenue and then just
assume a hundred thousand dollars ahead
plus so let's say that you've got 10
sellers doing 10 million so that's uh
a hundred thousand per salary for ten
people that's one million dollars and
then the commissions would be four
percent of 10 million so 400 000 so 1.4
million people 1.4 million dollars for
10 ad sales people for 10 million in
revenue um but then of course there was
like some account executives who would
help with that and then like uh
operations people but yeah that's
basically it bro you just did a shitload
of public math and um i forgive you
because you're my friend um you know we
don't do public math but that's easy so
for you to just do that listen
it's just not who we are it's not what
we do
did you follow i i tried to follow but
it's like you're speaking another
language you you did it 10 million in
it's 10 million in revenue
right which is about the same as theirs
right so you for all that headache of
employing all those people you saved
like one percent let's say of like the
commission rate now maybe you would feel
higher or maybe maybe you'd do a better
job than like the centralized service
would probably i would guess but um
but here's why it's also a better model
one time we had like goldman sachs or
something as an advertiser and we had a
story on [__] jerry and how [__] jerry
[__] jerry's like this meme instagram
account that says like funny stuff they
like launched like [__] jerry news or
something like that and i was like oh
well let's for this email by the way
every single sentence let's use the word
[__] it
and then like another time we talked
about donald trump and we're like this
entire email let's write it in the voice
of donald trump so like if you read it
to yourself it sounds like donald trump
and goldman sachs got really mad at us
and they're like you said [__] like
literally 84 times in this email like
we're not sponsoring you anymore
and i was like well good [__] off like i
don't care about you like you know screw
you [__] you but
katie sold the ad and her commission was
gonna get lost so i was like okay i
don't want to hurt you so i'm willing to
like not say certain stuff just because
i don't want you to experience the pain
but i don't give a [__] about that brand
if they want to like you know muzzle us
screw them right so now with this new
with this new uh setup it actually could
be a lot more advantageous for the
creator yeah katie's amazing by the way
we uh we work with her too she's really
good um so so what are the uh do we want
to do another one are we gonna wrap it
we can do one more maybe uh let's do
okay let me just do a you want an idea
or a life hack
a life hack all right so
so ben business partner ben not podcast
ben um
you know ben i might just refer to you
as god's been and the the other band i'm
going to have to say is is not god's men
so not god's ban was was entitled he's
you got to come up with yahweh and jesus
so he's visiting and i was like um
and so you know it's always interesting
right like in one way you know he he
came you know basically stays in my
house we we hang out for the week we get
a bunch of stuff done so he gets to see
a bunch of stuff in my world about how i
live life and i'm sure that's you know
somewhat interesting to him where he
sees some things he's like oh wow thank
god i don't do them that way and other
things you're probably like oh that's
cool like maybe i should be more like
that and the but the same thing happened
for me because
ben um on the last day i see ben and
he's like i'm like oh yeah you know
you're just packing up what are you
doing oh what are you writing down
because he's like hunched over his table
he's right he's like got a pen out he's
writing something by hand which is not
like you know we do everything on our
computer so i was like what are you
right now
and i noticed he's not holding a pen
he's holding a marker
and he he's drawing
and i was like then what are you doing
man what are you drawing and he's he's
drawing like a birthday card basically
on a giant piece of paper and he's got
six of them and he's drawn all these
cards and i'm like what is this
it's like my daughter's birthday what
are you doing he's like no it's my dad's
birthday and he's like ah it's a family
tradition we have he goes
every time it's someone on our family's
birthday
we all get out of get out like paper and
markers and we draw them like birthday
cards and it'll be like you know inside
jokes or like oh dad you're the man for
this reason you know i we always say
that you got the best whatever yo just
you got the best calves and so he draws
a picture of him with like huge calves
or whatever right you love this you love
the suns here's a picture of chris paul
holding a birthday cake for you singing
you happy birthday like this player on
the suns it's just like whatever it's
just goofy and i saw it and i was like
this is amazing and like everything he's
told me about his dad by the way by the
way his dad listens spot so shout out to
it shout out to andy um
his dad's amazing and like i'll tell you
one thing is amazing about his dad is
he's like
so his dad's a huge phoenix sons fan so
was ben i'm like oh did you get it from
your dad like your dad you know growing
up as a huge fan so that's why you are
he's like no it's the opposite growing
up my dad didn't really care about
basketball or the suns and i got super
into it and he's like my dad just does
this thing where like whatever each of
his kids is into
he like
he's like all right i'm into it too and
like not just like a small that's a
great dad movie the great dad move right
so i was like holy [__] i didn't even
i'm a dad now so i'm like i don't even
think about that he's like he's not just
supportive because i think that's that's
normal the common would be you're
supportive oh you like this great good
you know go on do your thing i'll i'll
show up at your game and i'll kind of be
you know doing the crossword on my you
know in my lap because i'm bored it's
not my thing
his dad said the opposite he's like oh
we like the you like the sun suns no we
like the suns and we
we love everything about the suns now
and we eat live and breathe the suns and
so for his other kid his other son is
does real estate
he's like oh you do real estate no no no
we do real estate and so he works for
his son for free just helping him sell
real estate
40 hours a week because he's like oh
yeah we got to sell some real estate i'm
in and so he's like a free employee
who's like hitting up linkedin he
doesn't pay him like he loves this
podcast because he'll hear growth ideas
and he'll be like oh so i'm going to do
that for my son's real estate business
wait that's it that's an amazing bat an
amazing dad and a horrible son pay your
dad dog
he doesn't want the money he's that
great of a debt and then the other son
like he does this like comedy thing and
he's like oh
comedy all right i'm in the comedy scene
now and like he does that and i was like
wow
i'm gonna do this so on the dad's side i
was like holy like ben ben works with me
andy basically works with me too he's
like he listens to every episode of the
podcast he responds to every email like
we put out he'll like he's not trying to
get special treatment he replies like a
fan like he'd be like oh yeah i do my
five-to-three tuesday he's like i love
number three or he's like the podcast oh
i love the way you and sam did this and
i'm like dude
how sick is that to have your dad become
your wingman for your favorite hobby or
your passion like i'm gonna do that so
that was the first learning the second
was this birthday thing he's like yeah
my mom like she came up with this early
on like you know love's not about the
gifts and like this is just a fun thing
we do for each other and we always do it
we
we did it you did what
this birthday poster so when you wake up
is this like a white person thing i
don't know about
i don't know but i mean
at my house when you wake up on your
birthday you wait
my mom would put puts like posters all
over the house that that all the other
kids like throughout
wow okay i don't know man
what did you play did you do this too we
don't
where did you get this no this is this
is new to me as well no no no
sam yeah we had it as well and honestly
it made my day it was like i would i
would be so eager to walk upstairs it's
kind of like when you walk upstairs and
you see like stuff around the christmas
tree it was like i felt that same joy i
walk over on the surface i see my signs
all over the place and i know that like
i get the breakfast that i want that day
yeah it's pretty cool this so so
i i basically like i don't even care
about my birthday anymore because it's
always like the same thing and i hate
the same i hate the sameness of life
there's so many things that are just the
same all the time like when facebook
came out with that you can write happy
it'll remind you happy birthday then
your wall becomes a thousand people who
don't really care about you writing
happy birthday i hate that because then
i feel guilty like i gotta reply yeah i
never reply and like you know and but
it's just the same thing right or what
other people do is uh let me throw money
at the problem which becomes a different
kind of burden it's like i gotta get you
a gift um i gotta think of something or
let's say i go buy you a nice card it's
like dude the birthday poster is so much
better than a hallmark card because it's
like hey it's like actually thoughtful b
is like kind of goofy and funny it's
like more entertaining and it's kind of
personal touch right and so
so i love this idea when we came home
from that farming conference my daughter
had drawn a poster that says welcome
home data and it's still the first post
like in my bathroom it's a poster on the
wall every day i go to the bathroom i
see welcome home data like the the
bathroom is my home which is you know a
little bit true and so i'm like this
personal poster thing is a great life
hack
and it got me thinking
i'm gonna start stealing everybody's
favorite family tradition
and so that's my new question for people
is like yo what are these like family
traditions you got like what are the
things that y'all do
and like people don't even know that
they're so like baked into their
operating line they don't even know them
and then you kind of keep digging and
you'll find them and if it's like if
it's a family tradition that's lasted
like you know 20 years of your life
it's probably awesome
and like i should steal that from my own
family what do you think
yeah i think that's good i'm trying to
think if i even have like my family
we're all atheists but we still pray
before every time we eat dinner like you
don't eat until you pray even like no
one believes in god um that's like an
interesting tradition
we do do birthday posters
um
i don't think we have any other
traditions like that i wonder i bet ben
has a ton a bunch but the one that we
started i think i talked about this so
we started doing our uh end-of-year
reviews where we uh
like do product reviews and and talk and
preview the year to come that's our
newest tradition i like that one a lot
yeah but that that's some new age [__]
though
actual product views like i love this
microphone or what do you mean
no i don't know just like uh
just reviewing like the year that what
was ben's 2021 or whatever and then
previewing yeah yeah um but no the other
like
we have a bunch of tradition we do have
a bunch of traditions um
like one of the simple ones we eat
waffles like every sunday morning and
that's like a thing i know i can look
forward to every week my wife makes
really good waffles with like
strawberries she does like goes all out
yeah that's just one
over the top it's one meal a week that i
know i can always look forward to and i
love it you don't have any sean no i do
i have some and now i'm like and i i
give credit to my dad my dad was really
the one who was bringing the like
the fun factor with some of these
whereas my mom's more like practical
whereas my dad would be like like once a
week he would do the same like the
whatever like the monday night dinner
and it's like oh dad's making dinner oh
sweet it's not because he's a better
cook but he would like he would just add
some showmanship to it so he would like
make he was like get this tray and so
everybody had their own circular tray
with like four dishes in it and and then
he would add a quarter and we were
always like yeah the coins there like i
got a quarter and like it's like an
equivalent of a mcdonald's happy meal
but like with a quarter
and there would be just like some
flourish there was always something that
was like a little extra that he would do
and um and like you know or like these
little things he would come home and he
put his wallet down but the game was i
would always steal the wallet and i'd
have he'd run and chase me i'd have to
hide it and like the game was like can
he get his wallet back and it's like how
do you turn that like two minutes of
coming home from like oh hey how's it
going like autopilot into
like something that's actually like fun
and breaks everybody's kind of like mood
for a second so he used to do that's a
great question to ask someone
what family trip what's a really good
family tradition yeah i'm going to steal
them too good idea got a buddy actually
that just came to mind i don't even i
don't think i want to steal this because
i don't think i could convince my family
to do it but his family did it and i
remember because he started dating this
girl and i was like how's it going you
know dating mike or whatever
and she was i think maybe the other way
around i was like how's he going dating
dating this girl she's like they got the
she's like they got this weird tradition
to kiss on the lips
yeah basically
that he was like
yeah they go to he's like i went i went
on the they're like annual like uh come
on annual family like vacation to tahoe
or whatever they went to a cabin
and i'm expecting skiing and all this
other stuff and there was but at night
they did this thing i'm like oh [__]
what did they do that's like blood cult
like what's going on and he's like yeah
they all read harry potter but like they
read it aloud and they read it like in
the voices
and he's like
oh my god
that's a bit more sitting there in the
circle yeah exactly but i was like but
to them
it was like their thing and i was like i
you know what like as as cringe as i
would feel doing that and i love harry
potter by the way but as cringe as i
would feel like doing you know
dumbledore's voice as i read the book
that would be a lot for me and
definitely a lot for me if i'm the
visiting boyfriend into that family that
was like a lot
but like you know respect to have a
family that's like willing to be a
little silly even as everybody gets old
like i really respect that and like if
that's your thing that's your thing all
right whatever like you know let me go
ahead and and read you know order of the
phoenix like in in the voice like let's
do this
you know like i say like cornrows and
tattoos or cornrows and sleeve tattoos i
respect that others do it but that ain't
for me
not for me
my new line i tweeted this out yes i
just bothered people but i i called i
was like product managers are the
bottled water of tech and it's just a
funny backhanded slide like nobody
nobody knows what to make of it like
it's a compliment but it's clearly kind
of an insult like i like bottled water
but i guess bottled water is
useless
and then somebody one-upped it and i'm
like oh that's my new [__] he goes he
goes they're more like the throw pillows
and i was like dude throw pillows such a
good disc because it's like
it's like
you know girls love them they look good
but they're completely [__] useless
and annoying and like annoying when you
actually need to go to sleep and so
calling something the throw pillow of x
is
just an awesome slam that i'm like
saving up in my back pocket to use
i met people at this conference that i
went to and there was like a lot of
listeners there and someone came up to
me goes so um
like when did you guys decide to make
the switch to go from talking about
business just being like 12 year olds
[Laughter]
yeah that's what they said
and he goes are you happy with that
switch and i was like
a i don't remember and b yeah i think so
[Laughter]
but i was like yeah there definitely was
like a decision
[Laughter]
but he wasn't trying to like roast me he
was like it was steph's uh fiance steph
smith's fiancee and he goes he's like i
love the pod um
but like when was that switch made where
you were gonna like go from like talking
about actual business to being 12.
when i was 12 we had a question like
this which was um
i was like
you probably know what it was like
um
when did you tell your dad you're gay
and it was like it was like
a viral question that went through our
middle school like covid it was like
instantly someone said this and people
realize like oh my god it's a hilarious
trap question there's no good answer to
this question and
literally everybody in every school in
the school district of texas was saying
this question for like three months and
then it went away that's what that
question is like oh when did you guys
decide to like switch the podcast up to
being like 12 year old idiot it's like
yeah
he just totally like alphaed me and i
was like oh
i don't remember calvin
it was pretty good and on that note
all right we're out see you
[Music]
you